hello students are you ready to be
thrown into a pool of the unknown you
will be critiqued and criticized in
front of your peers you will work long
days and long nights endlessly many
times without knowing what you are
looking for you will have to do the same
things over and over and over again your
project will haunt you from the moment
you wake up to the moment you sleep if
you're going to sleep that is if you're
ready for this then sit tight because in
this video i'm going to give you 10 life
tips that i wish i had when i was in
architecture school
[Music]
just over 10 years ago when i was just
18 years old i decided to make the
biggest investment of my life
and applied for architecture school
i spent about seventy thousand dollars
and six years of my life drawing
sketching getting criticized for my work
and falling asleep in the computer lab
it's kind of crazy when you think about
it with any other type of investment you
would want some kind of certainty in the
success of the outcome but when it comes
to our education we kind of go into it
with blind faith don't get me wrong i am
very happy that i made that decision 10
years ago and
i can't imagine myself doing anything
else but
recently
i have been thinking about how i could
have maximized
the returns on my investment
and how different life would be if i
knew 10 years ago some of the things
that i know now
so in this video i want to talk about 10
things i wish i knew or thought about
before starting architecture school
focus on building meta skills as well as
your hard skills so i remember this one
time i was working on a project with a
classmate and i was just really
frustrated because i felt like he was
not really contributing on the design
and i just felt like he wasn't really
pulling his weight i'm sure you are also
gonna come across a situation like this
because
there are a lot of group projects and
everyone kind of has different standards
and everyone has different ways of
working you know and some people are
just not that great to work with
but when you leave school
and work in an office this is something
that principals or project architects
have to do every day you know they need
to teach young interns
they need to explain things to clients
and consultants
and every day we're
solving problems that are not just
design related but people related so
these kind of
unfortunate but inevitable group
situations are kind of the perfect
opportunity for you to
practice how to communicate
and also how to inspire people
and how to explain things and i think
these are all skills that are gonna
become very helpful down the road
develop a skill that you can monetize
when i finished architecture school i
had around
50 000
in student loans and my
starting intern salary was 50 000
so
my mindset was to do
everything and anything possible to
pay this back as fast as possible
so i started looking at like looking for
side work like i knew how to draft
i knew how to do renders
i knew how to take
photographs
so i told all my co-workers and everyone
i knew
that if they ever needed any of these
things i could do it for a really really
good price
and so
i started getting some work
here and there
but
what i didn't realize is that the work
would take
way more time
than i had anticipated because i wasn't
actually that good at any of them
compared to a professional i also didn't
know how to charge properly to
compensate for my time
so it actually took me um a couple tries
to get to a level where i could actually
like offer my services professionally
for a decent fee if you are someone who
wants to offer some side services check
out places like upwork and fiverr and
see what level of competence is out
there and how much you can charge for
them something else that i learned is
that you should try to get into the
habit of
setting your own price and
asking what you think you're worth
obviously do the research
but
one of the things that i
realized makes a really big difference
in your fee
surprisingly
is not
necessarily the
um
the quality of the work but it's
actually the quality of the service so
if you are able to
communicate with your clients really
well
give them
timely responses and feedback you'll get
great reviews and you can charge a lot
more this is especially
prevalent now where you have people
charging like literally five dollars for
a rendering so i think the communication
and the service actually makes a really
big difference and i was actually pretty
surprised about this too
there's just so many ways for you to
make money these days that's not tied to
your job
and architecture school is a really
great place for you to explore some of
those skills
but it's your job to make it specific
and unique enough for it to be
marketable
grades don't really matter
this might kind of come as a surprise
but
unless you're applying for scholarships
or awards
grades don't really matter in
architecture school
as long as you pass everything i used to
get so mad about getting a b
because um
asian
but uh
i realized after graduating that people
just really look at your portfolio and
nobody really cares like you gotta see
instructors and maybe this is kind of a
contentious argument because
of course like you want to do your best
work
but
if i knew this in architecture school i
feel like i would have done
a couple things differently
for example if it came down to
sitting down and like really
understanding something
versus
finishing an assignment on time but like
really fast for a deadline so you gather
your friends and you pull your resources
i would have chosen to sit down and like
really understand the problem and the
solution even if it meant getting a
lower grade in the assignment you always
think that you're going to come back to
it and go over it later but you rarely
do
so if i actually knew that starting out
i think my strategy for school
would have been a little bit different
iterate and document the process
design is an iterative process so
don't be one of those people who falls
in love with their first idea
really good designers are able to
iterate through different options and
change their design drastically
really quickly
your design
is going to change as you try different
options and you might circle around and
come back to your initial idea but
because of this
it's so
so so so
important for you to document the
process
sometimes it's not about the idea but
the process
and how you got to that final point and
i've also mentioned this in my how to
create an architecture portfolio video
that in fact
the thought process is what firms are
more interested in seeing
not really beautiful renderings because
beautiful renderings are
so common these days
understand the law of diminishing
returns
just because design is an iterative
process it doesn't mean that you should
work on your project without any time
constraints
and
i think the law of diminishing returns
is just as applicable in design
and if you don't know what it is it's an
economic theory that tells us that
after a certain point
you will have reached an optimal level
of capacity
and adding any additional inputs will
actually reduce the returns on the
inputs so this over here is you
right in the morning or right after a
coffee break
you're pumping out your drawings and
iterations and
here maybe you go and have dinner
and it's starting to get late
and it's 3am
and
you can't remember what you've been
working on for the past hour
your computer's starting to crash
and you're forgetting where you saved
your file
i've been there and i remember it like
yesterday
try to understand your peak times and
when you're the most effective
i think everyone kind of has a time when
they're the most effective and everyone
also has the time when they're the most
creative when i was doing my masters i
realized that i was a better writer in
the mornings and that i could come up
with more interesting design solutions
in the evenings
so once i actually started implementing
this into my days
and started building a routine around it
i was just so much more effective and i
was getting so much more done
and i was getting so much more quality
work done learn from your crits
i remember this one time
i had a pretty
pretty bad
crit and
i was
fairly upset about it
not just because i worked on this thing
for
days and nights on end
not just because my worth was so
intimately attached to this project not
just because the juries poked some
really fair holes into my project but
because i was not really
able to answer a lot of the questions
that
that they threw at me i was so upset
that when the crit was over
all i wanted to do was just go home
shower
and go to sleep i just really wanted to
erase the memory of that entire crit
from my mind when i woke up i made it a
point to go through the notes that my
friend had taken for me
and
look at the project objectively and this
is actually the project that eventually
led to my thesis project which i won the
aia henry adams award for i think crits
are possibly the most
critical learning moments of your
project
because you have your group of juries
most of whom
have never seen your project before and
they're reacting purely
to your presentation of it
and it's a fairly accurate assessment of
your design and your ability to
communicate your ideas and you will have
bad crits that's for sure and you'll
also have good crits
[Applause]
what's really important is that you
think of them as an opportunity to get
critical feedback on your work
and on your thought process and you you
learn from that and you will continue to
have crits after school and into your
career so it's really important for you
to have
a growth mindset about this actively ask
questions and engage your profs
so school is an environment and probably
the few phases of your life where you're
gonna be surrounded with people who have
much much much more knowledge than you
and at the same time their whole job is
to teach you stuff don't be afraid of
asking dumb questions
remember that saying
he who does not ask a question remains a
fool forever meaning
you might look stupid asking that
question in class but if you don't ask
it you'll never know the answer
when instead you can just try to get
over the fear of looking stupid in the
moment
and honestly the chances are
if you have that question it's very
likely that other people have that
question too
learn how to communicate your ideas
clearly
so what i've learned over the years of
working in the field is that the
architects who become principals and
partners
they have one thing in common they are
incredible communicators
but i feel like we're not really taught
to do this enough were kind of thrown
into the deep end which is also why some
presentations can go really badly even
if they have amazing projects if you're
interested i actually have a few videos
on presentation techniques i'll leave it
right here as a general rule of thumb
try to spend some time before a deadline
to think about how you
are going to present your ideas and
please
don't just wing it
build systems around your workflow and
stay organized
so this might sound a little boring
but
this is one of those things that's gonna
save you so much time and energy down
the road
and
if you've been doing this regularly for
a few years it's gonna
it's gonna provide you with
a library of knowledge that you can
access anytime so there's certain
processes that we do very regularly
like producing renderings or laser
cutting or taking notes
where
a lot of the steps in the process can be
replicated
so for example
when i'm doing a rendering
i first try to identify which materials
are worth rendering and which are better
to do it in photoshop and my camera
settings preset for my exterior renders
and i have a preset for all my interior
renders so that i don't have to go in
and like adjust the settings every
single time
and in post-production i have all my
people and materials saved in a folder
and all the people are divided into
different folders based on what they're
doing i always try to save them in the
same spot every single time i think one
of my biggest regrets in life is that i
didn't start taking proper notes at an
earlier age i would write things down in
my notebook
and when i ran out of pages i would just
get a new notebook and
eventually forget about the thing that i
learned and written down so now i track
everything all of the new information
that i learned into notion into separate
categories so that i can look it up
later because if there's one thing that
life has taught me it is that you should
never trust your brain to store
information
of course there are certain things that
cannot be turned into a system
or are not worth turning into a system
but i think it's very important to kind
of always have this mindset build good
relationships
you can't get through architecture alone
that's a simple fact architecture is a
social profession you need to bounce
ideas off each other
you need that person who's gonna tell
you that your idea is [ __ ]
you need that person to
go on late night snack runs with you
you need that person that you can
complain to about your profs if you're
working in studio you will
naturally kind of develop these
relationships because studio is kind of
this like crazy
magical environment that's very hard to
replicate anywhere else
so
that's a part of what you're paying for
when you go to architecture school
there's all these people working on
their own project like drawing cutting
gluing and putting things together and
taking them apart
i can't even recount how many times i've
had like breakthrough moments in the
studio architecture is also a very small
community compared to other fields
that once you get into the workforce
a lot of people
know each other
or is once removed your friends in
school are going to be the people that
you're going to enter the workforce with
you
so eventually
they are going to become your
professional network
and
you know there is no better way to tell
if
somebody is going to be a good co-worker
and then
like doing a project with them um or
working through those late nights and
studios together
you'll you'll know exactly what that
person looks like when they're sleeping
you'll know what they smell like when
they have really bad meal
and you'll know all of their poor eating
habits yes
i still have friends from architecture
school from like 10 years ago that i
would vouch for because i know their
work ethic
and i know that they're going to be a
good fit at any firm so
although in this video i try to focus on
maximizing the returns on your
investment in time and energy the most
important thing you will actually get
out of architecture school
is not
really something you can buy with any
amount of money things like lifelong
bonds and memories and like appreciation
for beauty
and
like a life-changing experience that you
won't be able to get anywhere else it's
not going to be easy or fast but
it's going to teach you perseverance
amazing work ethic it's going to teach
you to trust in your own abilities you
learn to
work
yeah you learn how to work work work
yeah
hello darkness my friend
i've come to talk with you again
if you are just about to start
architecture school
or maybe you're already a few years in
um i'd love to hear which of these
things resonate with you
and
if you are an old fart like me
and you've already graduated
are there things that you wish you
thought about before you started
architecture school
that you could share with the rest of us
let me know down in the comments below
i'm really curious to hear what you
think
[Music]
you